hello countdown thing just did something
really weird and I think I've started so
yes let's get on with it
hi welcome to the last talk of the
conference futurology for dummies have
you had a good three days here at NDC or
five days if you did workshops until now
yes well done so yes I've had a great
time I actually I had this talk prepared
like a whole week ago and so I've
actually got to go to some talks I just
went to see Kendal Miller talking about
CPUs and how they work and yeah it's
interesting stuff so the reason for this
talk is that this year is the
anniversary of me getting my first job
in programming 1989 I left school at 16
and managed to land a job almost an
apprenticeship with a local software
company who taught me to code and so
I've seen everything that's happened
over the last 30 years and if you'd
asked me 30 years ago to predict where
we'd be now I would have got it
hopelessly wrong so I thought who better
then to predict where we're going to be
in 30 years from now me yes so that's
what we're going to do so let's just
take a quick look back at 1989 my first
job I turned up what did we have to work
with well this was the first server I
ever worked on this was a tendon 286 it
had two megabytes of RAM a hundred and
fifty megabytes of spinning hard disk
and we had eight programmers working on
it at the same time and it was not a
fast machine it ran on an intel 80286
processor and this was very very early
stuff so the specs of this processor we
it ran at eight megahertz so your
processor now probably runs somewhere
between four four and a half gigahertz
so it's like 500,000 times faster than
that it had it was just one call
none of this multi call stuff it had a
hundred and thirty four thousand
transistors on it each of those
transistors was 1.5 micrometers
micrometers across it was a 16-bit
processor it could address up to sixteen
megabytes of RAM if you could afford 16
megabytes of RAM because that was
expensive it would do 1.6 million
instructions per second integer
operations per second and flops weren't
a thing you could actually get a
coprocessor the 8287 which was a
floating-point coprocessor which would
do like a couple of hundred thousand
floating-point operations per second
this was what a two megabytes chunk of
memory looked like back in those days
and had 30 pins 8-bit data width so you
eight bits at a time off it and this was
what the hundred and fifty megabytes
hard disk looked like this is a five and
a quarter inch full height scuzzy hard
disk this cost about two thousand pounds
for a hundred and fifty megabytes and to
give you an idea because you can't
really tell from the slide of how big
this thing was that obviously is a
matchbox toy bus and if you think of it
as a matchbox toy bus that's probably
about right actually and so there were
eight of us working on this 286 and we
couldn't all just huddle around the
keyboard like in the sketch so we had a
dumb terminal this was a wise 50 and
this was a black-and-white it wasn't
black and white because actually black
and white was really expensive so it was
either green and black or orange and
black depending on which model you got
orange was nicer to sit and stare at all
day it was 80 by 24 characters it didn't
really do graphics it used the ANSI
character set to draw boxes using the
curses library yay
and it actually worked by pretending to
be a teletype back in those days so it
said I'm a printer connected to the
network send me print codes and that was
how that used to work what an actual
printer looked like in those days was
this this is I think it's an Epson LX
20s whatever this is it's a dot matrix
printer and this was what we used to use
to print out our code if we wanted to be
able to see more than 24 lines of it at
a time and did anyone if you don't
remember dot matrix printers if you're
like young and you've never experienced
one of these this is what it used to
sound like
that brings back memories doesn't it oh
yes so we did actually have laptops in
those days a lot of people think laptops
were more recently invented this was a
laptop back in 1989 this was a Compaq
portable SLT 286 this had a monochrome
tiny little low resolution screen it had
640 K of RAM and it weighed six point
four kilos so it was quite heavy and it
cost about six thousand pounds so we've
come quite a long way since 1989 in the
last 30 years these days in 2019 the
state of the art in CPUs in 2019 it's
not even an Intel CPU the state of the
art at the moment is the Apple a 12 X
that's the processor that's in the
iPhone XS and XS Macs this thing runs at
2.5 gigahertz it's got eight cores it's
got 10 billion transistors in it and
most of those are actually in not the
CPU calls they're in things like the
neural processing unit for doing much
more complicated stuff it's a 7
nanometer process now so they're much
smaller its 64-bit it can add rekt well
I don't know what it can address it can
probably address like millions of
gigabytes of RAM the phone that it comes
in has up to 6 gigabytes of RAM it
doesn't really worry about what MIPS it
can do anymore
it can do 5 teraflops 5 trillion
floating point operations every second
and it's not that long ago that to get
something that could do trillions of
floating-point operations per second
you were talking supercomputers in big
air-conditioned rooms built by Cray or
Nvidia or whatever and now we've got
that on a chip so there's there's the
comparison between though
two processors the thing from 1.5
micrometer micrometers to seven
nanometers it's hard to hard to really
visualize what that means so I've made a
visual aid
if this on the left is a 1989 transistor
on a two eight-six chip then this is how
much smaller the chip is today yeah it
is actually still there it's it's just
where are we
it's just about there it's a pixel it
stayed I managed to get it to stay to
one pixel but that is the affective
difference and this has happened this is
in accordance with Moore's law which
says the number of transistors in a
dense integrated circuit doubles about
every two years and actually after
Gordon Moore coined that law intel
revised it to every 18 months in line
with what they were actually achieving
and so we've got billions of transistors
on a chip that's smaller and faster and
cooler in temperature and in just Wow
and you know that's that's the progress
we've made there on the storage side of
things that hundred and fifty megabyte
discs that you would have to lift with
two hands those things were heavy now
Samsung have just demonstrated a 4
terabyte microSD card and so if you
actually put that 4 terabyte microSD
card next to that disk it would look
roughly like this that's about the size
comparison there and this state of the
art in laptops if you said to me mark
that talk was so good I want to buy you
any laptop you want no ok this is the
laptop I would ask you for this is the
current top of the range Lenovo
ThinkPad extreme it's got a six core ie9
CPU and a 4k touchscreen and 64 gigs of
ram and multiple solid state disks and
it costs less than half what that Compaq
used to cost so things have got smaller
they've got faster they've got better
we're just generally having a really
good time and that is without even
talking about the things that just
didn't exist at all in 1989 when I got
my first job in computing now the first
five
I still kind of throws me because I
think as that not being there all my
life the Internet okay the internet
existed ARPANET and ARPANET and all the
computers connected to each other but
the World Wide Web didn't exist in 1989
Tim berners-lee did not invent that
until 93 and so I spent the first four
years of my career where if I wanted to
know how something worked or how to do
something or more likely how to exit VI
I would have to go and I would get a
ring binder which had all the loose-leaf
documentation of which about 1/3 of the
pages said this page intentionally left
blank and 1/3 more of the pages were
blank but not intentionally
yeah we just didn't have the Internet it
wasn't a thing we certainly didn't have
Wi-Fi or mobile networks mobile I think
we had car phones like rich people had
car phones and the massive Motorola
bricks with like a briefcase attached
because batteries were still quite big
things in those days but no there was no
networking there was no Wi-Fi there was
no omnipresent data there was no cloud
obviously if you wanted hardware to run
your software on you had to buy that
hardware and get it delivered to your
office and set it up and we definitely
didn't have mobile devices we didn't
have phones in our pockets we didn't
have iPads we didn't have tablets we
didn't have any of that sort of stuff
the first one of those that popped up
really was the Apple message pad the
Apple Newton technology which came along
in 1993 did anyone ever use one of these
yeah were they yes that thing was
enormous that thing weighed over a pound
it was 640 grams so this was not light
I've got laptops now that weigh less
than this thing did now the equivalent
of that is the Apple iPhone XS which has
got just so much more memory the the
Newton had a two-color screen this
thing's got all the colors and that's 25
years from one of those things to the
next so we are making a lot of progress
in technology and it's kind of
accelerating let's look at what some of
that progress is it's getting faster so
chips are getting faster computers are
getting faster data transmission is
getting faster all that stuff getting
faster it's definitely getting smaller
we're now building things that are so
tiny that you actually can't see it
without a microscope or something it's
getting lighter so we can carry stuff
around I've got a computer on my wrist
right now that is probably many
thousands of times faster than that
tendon 286 was and runs for two days on
a charge it's getting precise err so
we're getting better at creating
precision hardware and so forth it's
getting powerful ER because I had to
start making up words to go into this
list and it's getting connected ER
because if you're going to make up words
then why not just go for it so
my new hobby is to take what I've
learned from those 30 years and try to
apply it so I can extrapolate from where
we are now over the next 30 years look
at the technology that we've got at the
moment and go right what's that going to
look like in ten years twenty years
thirty years time so that's what I'm
gonna try and do so if we extend Moore's
law out to 20 49 then we can expect that
a single processor is going to have
three hundred and twenty eight trillion
transistors on it I'm gonna be bold here
and go no it won't Moore's law it's it's
done if you're in Kindles talk on CPUs
transistors aren't going to get that
much smaller because we are actually
hitting up against the fact that that's
an atom now and you can't make things
smaller than an atom except maybe by
going to a smaller atom and there's only
so much compute you can do with a
hydrogen atom and you can't make the CPU
bigger to fit more transistors on it
because of the speed of light everything
on that core has to be able to stay in
the same state and so it can only be up
to a certain size otherwise it can't
operate as a single cohesive unit but
there are lots of possibilities for
where processes are going to go so right
now we've got arm CPUs are now being
built on a seven nanometer process Intel
you may have noticed have been
struggling to hit their 10 nanometer
target and they might be even jumping it
in just going straight to seven but with
just silicon on chips that's kind of
we're not going to get much smaller than
there so now they're looking at using
alloys like silicon germanium and using
germanium arsenide to alloy with the
silicon so that they can create smaller
transistors but even that's going to
take you down to maybe four nanometers
and then we've we've hit the effective
limit of what we can do with silicon
there's a
research going on at the moment into
graphene and carbon carbon nanotubes
because apparently there is nothing that
carbon nanotubes can't do my new
business plan is I'm going to invent a
toothpaste with carbon nanotubes in it
and I'm gonna charge 25 quid a tube for
it and and people will go why is this
good and I'll say carbon nanotubes and
they'll go yes we understand but they
are trying to make graphene chips and
processes and everything and that will
take us a little bit further because
that is getting to the point where you
treat each individual carbon atom as a
transistor or as a component in the
processor we also have photonic
processes light people are building
processors using photons as the unit of
information and bouncing those things
around the place there's a lot of
research going on into organic processor
design because the best computer that we
know of is inside our heads and even the
brains of something like a pigeon is
much more powerful than the Apple a 12x
and those are being underused really
pigeon brains we could probably like
harvest pigeons and use them to do
something more interesting I think and
then of course there's quantum processes
and we're at the very early stage of
quantum computing and it's just it makes
no sense I was trying to learn about it
and understand it so I could talk about
it and I've come to the conclusion that
if it makes no sense that's how you know
it's quantum quantum so a 64-bit
register in a regular CPU can hold a
number from might in Languedoc min value
down up to long max value which is quite
a big number
oK we've we had to switch to 64-bit
numbers for storing the number of
milliseconds since the first of January
1970 because otherwise dates would have
stopped working a few years ago in a
64-bit quantum computer each register
can hold 18 quintillion 446 quadrillion
744 trillion 73 billion seven hundred
and nine million five hundred and
fifty-one thousand six hundred and
sixteen different values at the same
time if somebody actually manages to
build a 64 qubit quantum computer it
will be able to crack at 1024 bit RSA
private key in less than a millisecond
and it actually make that 2040 make that
four thousand just just then a bit nice
it will just do it you just go what's
what are the factors of that and it'll
go there these and so it's gonna break
cryptography but then we're going to use
these quantum things to do new
cryptography with 18 quintillion bit
private keys and everything will just
keep going at the moment quantum
computing is quite complicated the best
way to do it involves using
bose-einstein condensate bose-einstein
condensate is a state of matter that
only exists at naught point 1 Kelvin or
minus 273 point seven degrees Celsius
I'm not translating that into Fahrenheit
Americans just do it yourselves but you
know 30 years ago the 286 and now this
we've got what we got now so in 30 years
time it's entirely possible that I'll
have a quantum computer on my robot
wrist that I've had my arm replaced with
so trends we are seeing at the moment
things that have just kind of started
just kicked off I did a bit of research
for this as I was making the next slide
I connected to my route or I've got on
Netgear or B Reuter and I said give me a
list of all the things that are
currently connected to the Wi-Fi in my
house eight computers desktops and
laptops eight phones and tablets 2x
boxes one PlayStation 2 Nintendo
switches the TV in the living room three
Sky Q boxes to fire TVs my wristwatch my
wife's wristwatch six Amazon echo
devices Alexa or whatever you want to
call her three Kindles quite a lot of
the light bulbs the doorbell the washing
machine when the washings finished in my
house the washing machine sends a
message out over the Samsung smartthings
hub and I get a little popup on the TV
that goes the washings finished as
printer as a camera as and you know that
was just I ran out of space on the slide
out of all those things that are
connected to the Wi-Fi these are not
really what you would think of as a
computer so the eight computers and the
Xbox is in the PlayStation those have
all got Intel processors in them
everything else has got an ARM processor
and is not really a general-purpose
computer I mean okay the the phones and
the tablets and the switch is the TV to
a certain extent you can write
applications on it and so forth
the sky cube boxes you've got Netflix on
there now the fire TVs but the things in
the right-hand column are not really
general-purpose computers they're kind
of single-use devices or very limited
use devices but we've still got software
running on them and they're still
communicating over the Wi-Fi with each
other to do things and so it's becoming
increasingly important to be able to
develop software that runs on things
that aren't what you would think of as a
computer and I'm trying to put useful
stuff in here so that you can leave and
kind of go that was interesting to me
I'm going to go and
investigate more into that and start
building my skills on that and so if you
want to kind of be ready for this next
wave of things we could call it the the
Internet of Things there's somebody
coined that already I'm claiming it then
you can go you can leave here and or
just right now get your phone out go
onto Amazon and order yourself a
Raspberry Pi 3 B+ this is like a
thousand times more powerful than
anything we had in 1989 this is the kind
of standard for an ARM processor you can
run Linux on it you can run a bunty you
can run Windows 10 core on it you can
program it with dotnet core or C or
Python you can do all sorts of things
with a Raspberry Pi and you can use it
as the basis for a kind of hardware
project before you take it to the next
stage of working out exactly what
hardware you need that's a reasonably
powerful thing if you want something a
bit more powerful if you want something
that you can use as an actual games
console to run retro games then you can
get the Asus tinkerer board this is a
really nice piece of kit these are about
60 pounds and they're pin compatible
with the Raspberry Pi so you can use the
same devices and hats and things if you
want to go smaller and have something
that doesn't have very much processing
power at all but still runs Linux and
has Wi-Fi and Bluetooth and 512
megabytes of RAM then this is the
Raspberry Pi 0 W the W is for Wireless
so there was one before that you
couldn't connect to anything which is
kind of why you can get one of these and
you can use this as the basis for your
automated artificially intelligent waste
paper basket so you're gonna attach a
microphone to it and say waste paper
basket come here and open your lid and
I'll just try and drop things in there
so yeah you can get those this there's
lots of these boards at the moment it's
a big area you can get a humming board
an orange pie a banana pie and
Oh droid those are all computers those
are single board computers that run an
operating system you've also got Arduino
and Arduino is a bit different that's a
microcontroller so Arduino it's not a
general purpose computer and it doesn't
have like file system and all this sort
of stuff you don't you load code onto it
and it just runs that code without
having an underlying operating system so
that's why I oughta we know is in
brackets but still lots of fun to be had
there and to get started with this
this is NBC I'm assuming most people are
kind of dotnet developers you can get
dotnet core now to compile to arm 64 and
arm 32 there's the karate project which
does ahead of time native compilation
don't ask me where that's at with
returns to support and everything but
it's there there's a great website JSON
1800 where he will teach you how to
build your own operating system from the
ground up for the Raspberry Pi if you
follow Alexandre you tell on Twitter
he's xoo FX he did that course in
c-sharp and nets and compiled it with
karate and created a Raspberry Pi
operating system using c-sharp Microsoft
it's not early preview anymore and it's
not on my get it's now part of dotnet
core 3.0 preview to system device GPIO
gives you drivers for talking to the
GPIO pins on the Raspberry Pi and that
is a first-class feature in net core 3.0
if you want something a bit higher level
that gives you kind of nice drivers for
things like cameras and microphones and
so forth then uno squared up get up to
io / raspberry io gives you nice
friendly libraries for talking to other
bits of those things so that's probably
not a bad thing to at least be starting
to be aware of
because we are moving away from big
systems and big computers and we're
moving more towards building computing
into almost every aspect of our lives so
that's something that's that's a trained
we also have now the things that are
effectively primitive technology today
so there are things that we've just kind
of started iterating on in the same way
that thirty years ago we thought that
printer was pretty neat at dot matrix
printer which hammered pins through a
ribbon onto a piece of paper you get
color dot matrix printers which hammered
Riblet pins through four different
colored ribbons and so each line that
they printed they'd have to go backwards
and forwards four times through each of
the different ribbons to build up a
color image and now we've got 3d we've
got photo printers and everything else
but actually one of the things that
we're very much in the early stages of
is user interface so user interface at
the moment is on either a touchscreen or
it's a screen with a keyboard and you
sit there and you type and you drag a
mouse around and all this sort of stuff
we just hitting possibly the next stage
of user interface design which is
augmented reality or virtual reality
where you get into a digital space and
you interact with it using natural
gestures this is coming out in q1 this
year recording to oculus this is the
oculus quest who's got an oculus rift or
an HTC vive hope okay so I mean it's
it's awesome the the rift and the vive
both or vive I don't know as pronounced
I've only ever seen it written I've
played with a rift and it is immensely
cool but it's also
it requires a 1,500 to 2,000 pound
computer with a really good graphics
card in order to make it work and you're
attached to that computer by a big thick
cable and you can't exactly wander
around a lot
the oculus quest there's already the
oculus go which is like a gear VR that
you don't need a phone for but they're
just about to start shipping the quest
this is almost as so it's got most of
the same functionality as the rift six
degrees of freedom it's got the two
touch controllers is got roughly the
same resolution but it is an entirely
self-contained headset so that's it what
you can see on the screen there that's
the whole thing you don't need a
computer it's got a Snapdragon 835 which
is actually 2017 s phone CPU and they
reckon that it's got roughly the
performance of an Xbox 360 which is just
nuts and this is going to ship for four
hundred quid which is the same price as
the oculus rift and you don't need a PC
and you can put it on and just wander
around with it and it's got inside out
tracking and all sorts of stuff and now
that these are starting to actually the
controllers and the SDKs are getting
more mature we're starting to see some
actual sensible software get built for
these I want to show you my favourite
example from last year which is beat
Sabre has anyone played beat Sabre so
this would be boring for you but if you
don't even know what it is check this
out because this is awesome
nope it's not awesome
why won't my video play
okay sorry
no it's on the machine
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so yeah that's some beat saber
which is like amazing a good fun almost
got them sued by Disney slash LucasArts
but it's like it's a rock band style
game except you're hitting musical
blocks with lightsabers and you look
like a totally ticked while you're
playing it because nobody else can see
what you see we've got that music
banging away in your head that's
currently available on PlayStation VR
and oculus and veve but that's going to
be one of the launch titles for the
oculus quest and it's not particularly
complicated graphics or anything so
you're just going to be able to go you
know a bit saber yes and that will
pretty much be your cardio as well for
the day so so that's pretty good that's
virtual reality the other thing we've
got is microsoft's hololens augmented
reality and augmented so virtual reality
you put a headset on and it transports
you somewhere else entirely and if
somebody walks very quietly up they can
punch you in the face and you won't even
see it coming
augmented reality lays digitally
generated assets over the real world so
you've got a see-through lens and then
it lays stuff over it the first thing we
got that actually did this was microsoft
hololens and you may have seen Raphael
did a talk about a are the current state
of AR in about a month's time so towards
the end of this month Microsoft are
doing a press conference in Barcelona at
the Mobile World Congress and the guy
who does hololens is going to be there
so while they haven't said hololens to
specifically fingers crossed we're going
to get to see it hololens is a mystery
Intel CPU that was made specially for
Microsoft it's got their holographic
processing unit two gigs of RAM the main
problem with
if you've had a play with it is it's got
a 35 degree field of view which means
it's like holding an a4 piece of paper
out at arm's length that's what they can
actually fill and if anything outside of
that just disappears hololens - this is
just rumors but they're talking about a
Snapdragon 850 CPU which is the one that
they're currently using for Windows
always-on laptops with LTE and so forth
the second generation holographic
processing unit which has got built-in
tensor calls for doing artificial
intelligence a 70 degree field of view
so that's like what holding up an a3
piece of paper but that's probably going
to be fairly decent actually and that's
let's hope that's what they're going to
be telling us about at the end of this
month
there's also magic leap which finally
went from yay look we're gonna make this
amazing thing that makes Wales leap out
of the floors of gyms and crash down and
actually landed and it was this and yeah
they'll get there eventually but you can
get one of these now you can all well
that you can get one of your friends in
the States to order one for you and then
ship it over to you but this is fairly
decent let's see if this video will work
shall we
god damn it
I don't know why these aren't working I
hate my life I've got some grabs from it
this was the launch thing for the
cheddar live news how can I not be doing
any coding and still have my demos not
work just not fair one of you is a Jonah
and you're following me around this is
an app called cheddar live news and it's
basically this guy is just wandering
round his house and he's got a little
the little magic leap controller thing
in his hand and he puts his some his
magic leap on and he just starts walking
around the house and every now and then
he goes click and a screen just appears
in front of him with the news on it and
you sort of think oh that's that's
really impressive now you've got a TV
that follows you around and you don't
have to stay in one place to watch it
there are a couple of problems with
magic leap and obviously the first one
is oh my god cool chains yes maybe in
your house if either you're the only one
there or everybody else is also wearing
magic lips then you could just about get
away with that but you're not going out
looking like that but the thing with
this is and with hololens as well is
this is primitive technology this is us
building effectively the prototypes so
what magic leap have built here in
technology terms is the Newton message
pad and over the last 25 years the
Newton well it took 13 years for the
Newton message pad to go to the first
iPhone which got a lot smaller and a lot
lighter and the battery lasted longer
and you know we went from 640 grams to
135 grams we went from two colors to all
the colors we went from
at 640 K of ram up to a gigabyte of ram
so these things get smaller and lighter
and more polished and more usable fairly
fast and so it doesn't seem that
unreasonable to suggest that what is
currently a fairly big chunky stupid
looking thing that you're gonna stick on
your head and hide from everybody will
by 2031 let's say have become something
that looks like a fairly small pair of
sunglasses not necessarily those
sunglasses those are just the ones that
were easiest to remove the background
from when I stole the image from Google
Images
but this magically right now will
already put these screens in space in
front of you it looks something like
this so he's got he's actually got
multiple screens here
he's got there's there's this screen
here which has got cheddar news and
there's this screen over here which is
charting something maybe it's his
microbrewery that he's got running
somewhere and that's how the beers
fermenting or something
because he looks like that sort of
person but this does raise the
possibility that this might be the 2020s
might be the last decade where we have
these things or screens on our laptops
or projectors and big screens up at the
front here because if we can make
screens just pop into existence in front
of us wherever we are and whatever size
we need them to be then that's going to
be so much better I my computer can be
reduced down to a keyboard I'm guessing
the screen that appears in space in
front of me is probably going to be
touch be weird to have to use a mouse
with a screen that's not really there
and we'll the thing is we'll get that
because we do technology jumps in really
weird stages so we can I go we can make
anything appear in front of us and we
can do anything with it
let's make screens appear in front of us
and carry on presenting two-dimensional
flat rectangles of information
for us to interpret but that's where
we'll go first but we'll eventually who
remembers this from the hololens launch
demo this guy walks into a room and goes
I'm playing Minecraft and it Maps the
room works out where all the flat
surfaces are and goes minecraft and even
there's like put a bit of TNT in the
wall and then blew it up and it blew a
hole through the actual wall and you
could see Minecraft outside and so
that's going to be the next stage is
where we're kind of just creating
whatever we want to create and sticking
it in the world around us and
interacting with it as though it's
really there there's one thing that I
didn't have a chance to put into this
presentation because I was too busy
doing my PubCon talk which I only found
out about yesterday from r-fl which is
leap motion so the guys who did the
little aluminium Mars bar that can see
all your fingers they've got a kind of
3d printed yourself and build it your
self thing called Project Northstar
which actually looks completely nuts
because one thing leap motion are really
good at is tracking what your hands are
doing and so this is their view of what
augmented reality is going to be like
and it's just like so hold your hand out
like that it's got tabs down the side of
it in your vision and you can pull one
of them out and that's your mobile phone
and so this is you know whether this is
ten years twenty years thirty years this
is this is where things are going and
once it gets down to the point where
it's basically a pair of sunglasses then
it's not going to be a matter of whether
you're going to wear these things or not
it's going to be a matter of whether you
buy them from Ray Ban or Oakley who are
going to become the super computer
manufacturers of the fourth decade this
is a really nice this is desktop
augmented reality which you can build
with AR kit which is Apple's thing and I
think it works with AR core as well but
yeah you can start building augmented
reality experiences today or virtual
reality experiences today to be
ready for when it comes time that your
businesses we're throwing out all the
screens I'm replacing them with
contextual information mapped onto
reality so if you want to be ahead of
that curve the things that you really
need to know is you need 3d graphics and
modeling so you need to understand I
always like to compare this to when I
was learning programming on a zx81 back
in 1982
if you wanted to preach something at
particular coordinates on the screen you
would say print at 10 comma 12 and it
would go 10 in and 12 down and then
print whatever you wanted it to do
we now have effectively render at and we
just have an extra coordinate but then
you also have to worry about the
rotation in three-dimensional space and
the size and you've got all these
transforms and everything you have to do
it's quite complicated but the SDKs that
are out there make this quite easy and
you also need to start getting into
spatial design to make sure that you
leave enough space between things and
that they're relating to each other
properly and that if this thing's
supposed to be in you see some the new
Pokemon go with the new AR kit stuff
if the Pokemon is this side of the
lectern I can see it but if it goes
round the back it can actually peek out
from behind a real thing and it clips
off the bit that's behind the lectern
even though all it's actually doing is
drawing something right here but it
works there so you know this is the
stuff that we need to be getting into
and the new interaction models so
following hands around in space and
working out what they're doing so and
again this is something that for.net
developers probably the easiest way to
get started with this is with unity 3d
which is a games engine or it started
out as a games engine but if you look at
what people are doing with it now
they're doing business applications
they're doing automotive applications
people are doing all sorts of things
with unity now
and doesn't matter if you're an artist
or a 3d person or whatever they've got
an asset store and you can go to the
asset store and say I want penguins and
there goes our here's everything from a
high-definition absolutely realistic
emperor penguin to something that looks
like a penguin made out of Lego there's
there's an engine kit called a guy who
makes engine kids and he has a website
more mountainous company does a driving
game kit and stuff it's a really good
way to get started if you're looking for
a book on that I recommend the unity in
action the second edition from Running
Press you can go onto YouTube there's a
guy on YouTube who just seems to support
himself using patreon search for bra
keys and he's got loads of tutorials on
there and there's some great code
tutorials on how to actually program
three-dimensional objects and graphics
and so forth using things like sine and
cosine and tangent and various other
bits and pieces that's on cat like
coding comm there will be a link to
links at the end of the talks I don't
worry too much about that so that's
that's where we're going with UI and
user experience in my estimation the
next way is manufacturing and
manufacturing at the moment
pull raw materials out of the ground
take them to a factory the other side of
the world make them into the thing that
you want them to be then take them back
to the other side of the world put them
into an Amazon warehouse and let people
order them and then take them to
wherever you ordered it from in
sometimes as little as two hours which
is just nuts and we think that's pretty
good
Bert's where that's going to go I think
is 3d printing so 3d printing this is
the 3d systems stereo life that graphic
apparatus this was the first 3d printer
in 1992 stereo life the graphic is where
you cure resin with a laser beam and
gradually extrude an object from a
liquid resin this in night
ninety-two would set you back $100,000
okay
this is the version one RepRap
reproducing rapid prototyper or
replicating rapid prototyper this was
invented at the University of Bath was
invented all over the place but they
built this one at the University of Bath
in 2007 so 15 years later and you could
order some bits you get some bits of
wood and if you get some bits of tube
and if you knew somebody who had one of
these printers you could print all the
other bits yourself except the circuit
boards and so that was why it was
replicating because you could use a rep
wrap to make a rep brand that was 2007
12 years later you can now go onto
Amazon and search for 3d printer and
you'll just get pages and pages and
pages of things that cost less than 200
pounds and you can get yourself 3d
printer and hook it up and I absolutely
recommend it it's great fun you can just
make almost anything you want in almost
any color as long as it all the same
color
so a lot of these are actually just kind
of multi generation later rep wraps but
we're starting to see things what does
that look like to you because to me that
looks like an iMac okay so we're already
at the point where somebody has taken
the concept of a 3d printer and turned
it into a consumer product that looks
like it's been designed to sit on a
table in your living room and this costs
just over 200 pounds and it's it's a by
all accounts it's a very good 3d printer
okay
that will print so you can print one
color at a time if you want something
that's multiple colors you have to break
it down into the bits that are different
colors print them individually and then
glue them together unless you've got
just under 1700 pounds in which case you
can get this same company this is a
color 3d printer I
didn't know when I started doing this
research for this talk that this existed
but this comes with a essentially blank
resin blank filament and it has an ink
tank with colored ink in it and as it's
printing it mixes the colors with the
blank filament and it will do full-color
3d printing and it's 1700 pounds that's
less than I spend on my laptops or on my
my desktop machines I spend more than
that on lots of things
I'm definitely getting one of those as
soon as I've managed to hide 1700 pounds
under the floorboards where my wife
doesn't know about it now admittedly at
the moment that's still at the
dot-matrix point of things okay so it's
still low resolution printing but you
can do high resolution printing this is
the form too from form labs this will
cost you this is essentially the same
technology as that first SLA so this is
you get risen and it uses a laser and it
cures it and this does really high
resolution 3d printing this will set you
back around three and a half thousand
pounds so you can have this or you can
have two full couple of 3d printers if
you spend five and a half thousand
pounds you can get a wash and cure set
that go with it and you've got like a
proper in your house manufacturing
process the only issue with this so if
you go for one that works with the tube
of filament those things cost about a
tenner
for a roll of that filament if you go
for this then a bottle of the resin that
this uses to do printing will set you
back one hundred and fifty pounds so
this is not a cheap thing but if you
want to actually go into business
manufacturing and designing things and
you want to prototype stuff then this is
great and you can that's not an
unreachable amount of money this is the
sort of thing that prints and you can
see that it's really nice high
resolution very smooth things and you
get different colored resins to do
different colored things and this is
just at the start of the printing 3d
printing
nology so again from 20 years in 1989 we
had to color dot matrix printer with
that lovely noise that it made 20 years
later we had the HP photosmart AE 6 to 6
which you could take your memory card
out of your camera and plug it into that
printer and it would produce prints
though where every bit as good as the
ones that five years earlier you'd have
had to take a film in to boots and have
them develop it by the way that is why
some of the earlier stuff in here there
aren't that the photos of those things
are not that great because we didn't
just carry cameras around with us all
the time if you wanted a photo of
something you had to have a camera and
put film in it and then take the photo
and then go and get it developed and
then somebody between now and then would
have had to digitize it and put it on
the internet so yes in the very near
future and we come of this is already
stuff that exists in laboratories there
will be 3d printers that can actually
print gadgets just no additional bits
need to be put in they've got lots of
tanks or supplies of various different
materials and somebody has actually
successfully used a 3d printer to build
a functioning remote control for a
television they didn't do anything to is
no assembly there were no components put
into it it built from essentially raw
materials a functioning remote control
for a television that exists now so
again extrapolate that forward for a bit
also food so we actually have quite an
issue with food we're kind of running
out of it farming it is very intensive
there are going to be 10 billion people
in the world by 20 49 and we need to
feed them all and so that's quite tricky
even farming that much food but that is
another thing this is 3d printed meat it
looks kind of gelatinous there and you
kind of go I don't really want that that
looks like orange jelly I like orange
jelly but I don't want it in the
Birger but apparently when you cook it
then it goes and it looks like cooked
meat and it feels like cooked meat and
it tastes like cooked meat in the far
future and by far future here I am
talking about maybe 30 maybe 50 years in
the future we are just going to get to
this point where you go computer make
meaty the way the replicator worked in
Star Trek was it condensed energy into
matter which was we maybe a little way
from being able to do that there's a
book if you haven't read the Dimond age
by Neal Stephenson I highly recommend it
this is about a nanotech future where
essentially there is a feed so in the
same way that you have water and
electricity coming into your house
people just have streams of molecules
coming into their houses and printers
that can assemble things out of atoms
and molecules
it's called Dimond age because if you're
making things from atoms carbon is more
abundant than silicon and so diamond
becomes cheaper effectively than glass
and so all the windows and everything in
this world are made of diamond instead
of glass which is nuts it's a great book
highly recommend it and then of course
we need to talk about artificial
intelligence and I've got five minutes
left to cover the whole of artificial
intelligence so let's do this so
artificial intelligence started about 70
years ago with cheering when I know if
you can't tell a difference between a
computer and a real person then that
computer is intelligent in 1956 McCarthy
and Minsky coined the term artificial
intelligence at a conference in 1973 the
light Hill report came out for all the
research that was being done into
artificial intelligence the light Hill
report said machines would only be ever
be capable of experienced amateur levels
of chess and for us futurologists
because we're all futurologists now
right this is something that will have
to come up against repeatedly where we
say this is going to happen in people go
oh no that's a bit far-fetched and it
doesn't take long to get to the point
where we prove them wrong 1980s bit of a
expert systems prologue just just ignore
the 80s they don't really count 1997
though deep blue beat garry kasparov
three games out of four at chess ha
light he'll shut up
in 2002 who the first consumer
artificial intelligence popped up with
the Roomba which is just the little
robot that will go around and Hoover
your house as long as you don't have
kids like mine who make it impossible
for Roomba to go more than three feet
without bumping into one of their
sodding toys in 2005 this is when Boston
Dynamics made that dog that could run
across battlefields in 2005 if it fell
over that was it that was your 10
million robot but now it can get back up
again and if it can't get back up it
calls another dog that's got a special
thing attached to its back have you seen
the one where one gets to a door that it
can't open so it calls its door opening
friend have we learned nothing from
Jurassic Park so yes in 2011
IBM's Watson played Jeopardy and it
played it properly it played it by
listening to the questions that were
being read from the thing it asks for
them off the board and it worked out the
answer and then it put it in the form of
a question and it trashed the to human
jeopardy record holding champion people
and that was like a massive
supercomputer and it cost millions and
millions of pounds but also in 2011
Apple released Siri and in 2014 Amazon
introduced Alexa and also in 2014 we got
the first driverless cars actually
driving around California and so far
they've only killed one pedestrian which
is quite impressive they've got millions
of miles on them I've killed more
pedestrians than that and I've probably
only driven about 200,000 miles in my
whole life and they deserved it in 2016
in 2016 Google invented the Google
assistant which spies on you
also in 2000 so when Garry Kasparov got
beaten by deep blue
they went our well chess though chess is
quite easy nobody will ever beat a human
player at go
so yes Ben forward another 19 years and
alphago beats a 9 dan professional for
one using a Monti Kart
they didn't even teach alphago to play
go they just went here are the rules of
go and it played against itself for a
bit it actually worked it out from base
principles now we have neural processing
units so the a 12x most of those 10
billion transistors most of those 5
teraflops that it can do are in its
neural processing unit that exists just
to do AI and it's mainly to map the
world around it and everything else
we've got
Nvidia putting tensor calls into there
their CPUs and their GPUs the Snapdragon
805 5 has got AI circuitry built into it
the hololens 2 has probably got
something like that we can program chips
out in the field field programmable gate
arrays are being used for artificial
intelligence it's really difficult to
write this stuff so you can just go to
the cloud and go hello I would like to
consume some artificial intelligence and
machine learning please Microsoft
cognitive services Google cloud AI IBM
Watson as a service you can do all these
sorts of things if you want to start
mucking about with this and trust me you
do want to start mucking about with this
if this is the one thing that you take
away make sure that you are at least
keeping pace with the development of
machine learning because this is the
thing that's going to change all of our
jobs within the next 10 years if you
want to go home and get something to
play with Microsoft's machine learning
Nets if you're a dotnet guy you like
c-sharp then ml net there's lots of
great examples you can go and start
working with that open CV the open
computer vision project that's works
with Python C++ Java I think there are
mappings for c-sharp for that
caresse is a deep learning library for
python Google's tensorflow
is incredibly powerful but oh my god is
difficult to use if you want to build
your own assistant then there's Mycroft
as well
so you can go and you can get all of
these things from from these various
websites again there are links coming
towards the end so we've also got
quantum computing which I really don't
have time to go into but there are some
links on the thing that you can do
that if you want to get started with
quantum computing then there's a quantum
development kit that you can play with
and there's a great book called
computing with quantum cats by John
Gribbon nanotech which is the diamond
age sort of stuff
we've got nanomaterials and multiple
ways of building nanotechnology
biomimetics and speculative things if
you want to get started in nanotech to
get ahead of the curve then get a
bachelor's degree in material science
get a masters degree in material science
get a PhD in material science and apply
for a research position at a really good
university so like Oxbridge Harvard MIT
not Princeton all right maybe Princeton
so I'm I am a bit over I'm gonna take a
couple of extra minutes cuz I just want
to say this is where I think we're going
so next 10 years to 2029 none of this
matters because we're getting hit by the
Apophis asteroid where's the one in a
hundred and fifty thousand chance but
I'm really counting on it because I'm
gonna be at the top of the mounting now
bring it because I'm tired but no I
think in 10 years time augmented reality
is going to be pretty much everywhere
whether we're using it walking down the
street chasing Mario coins on our daily
run I don't know but we will be using it
a lot more and it's going to start
changing the actual shape of the world
around us because a lot of things won't
need to exist anymore it just needs to
look like they do we will have
self-driving vehicles self-driving
lorries self-driving lorries that stay
in the slow lane on a two-lane dual
carriageway and don't try and overtake
they anyway it's a bit of a thing there
we're going to have automation in things
like manufacturing and farming and
logistics and knowledge work and we're
going to start seeing massive job losses
in society is going to start to fall
apart in 2039 and really hope Ilan's
gonna have some things landed on mars by
that point when they go to Mars they're
going to be able to do that in part
because they're going to be able to take
3d printers with them that will be able
to just pull materials out of the
surface of Mars and build whatever they
need when they get there we will no
longer be getting things delivered by
Amazon we will just be buying the
blueprints for something and printing
them in our houses because we're going
to start to hit the start of the Nano to
age at that point robots will be doing
pretty much all the jobs by that point
and we will be learning to improve
ourselves and augment ourselves and
offload tasks to artificial intelligence
to help us do things and all this other
stuff and by 2049 we will either be
living in a utopia with robot dogs that
we are taking for a walk at the end of
our extended arm but there is no reason
if all these other things 3d printing
and artificial intelligence and
everything else there's no reason by
2049 why we could not be in the post
scarcity Society of Star Trek where we
don't actually need capitalism anymore
because there is enough of everything
for everybody the other alternative is
that everything's melted and we're all
at the bottom of the sea and none of
this matters in which case I
just whatever but yeah that is where I
would like us to get to and optimistic
so if there is anything in this talk
that you were interested in and you want
to learn more about it I made a website
I've never done this before I made an
actual website that you can go to right
now this isn't an I'll do a git push you
can go to the website there's links to
all the things that I've talked about in
this talk ml don't net and artificial
intelligence and all this sort of stuff
sorry for going a couple of minutes over
I hope you think it was worth it I've
hopefully had a great conference hope
see some of you at PubCon and other
people at other conferences and thank
you very much for listening to me
good bye